bruh
[Music]
love
i got
[Music]
some people say
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is rob jefferson and i
successfully survived hall h
it is my second time in san diego my
first time doing hall h um the first
time i went to san diego was i want to
say 2019 actually right before
everything went nuts in the world but uh
honestly it was kind of it was so
overwhelming i just did like the
standard con where like i walked the
floor for a few days
and then went home
that was basically it
see that x-men cover right there
where wolverine's like
we got that guy with a crazy red and
white looking outfit yeah that is
tell me about uh creator vindicator okay
so so ignore the camera so uh vindicator
yeah but it's about the closest you get
to captain canada so that's like when
you said that i was like is he playing
indicator
yeah you're the social media guy make
sure you take a picture and then throw
it up on uh
going up on twitter or whatever
that is insane
yeah look how sharp this thing is
right and check it and even if i open it
open it up all the way up to
1.7 right
yeah so that's close enough
it's it's a it's ridiculous how short
this lens is
all my favorite camera is let go what
your all-time favorite camera is the
leica it wasn't until i got this i never
used the leica until i got a q2 yeah and
now i absolutely love it so yeah i would
say man like
yeah i can i can see why because like
the m11 is their manual it's the
rangefinder the manual version of this
the m11 will cost you like nine thousand
dollars for the camera alone
and then like another five or five to
eight thousand dollars for the lens and
it's probably one of the most expensive
camera systems you're ever going to buy
but
worth it man
yeah look at that
at what point did you decide that geek
culture explained what's going to be
camping out our qualities this year
a big chunk of that
of camping out for hall h is because
it's like it's tradition
it's ceremony right it's it's it's
to use a really crude phrase right it's
popping your cherry at san diego
comic-con right it's one of those things
where it's like if you plan on going to
san diego comic-con more than once
everybody has to do this at least once
it's a rite of passage i'm in freaking
hall age i wanted to be in that crowd
who was like going nuts when there was
like some big announcement
rounding out phase 5 we have a series on
disney plus this is very special it is
going to be an 18 episode first series
uh first season 18
[Applause]
it was crazy being in there but i would
say that's probably the biggest reason
why
i wanted
uh to go to san diego this year and
actually do hall h
is to be a part of that crowd who's
going crazy and screaming and all that
kind of stuff
uh when all this stuff is announced by
really marvel studios
kind of warner brothers i guess
um black adam did kevin hart ever get
jealous
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's your name
mason but may well hold on one second
i'm going to get to your question a
second but mason buddy that was a great
question thank you uh the truth is
yes kevin hart gets jealous of
everything
but also i want and i can i'm pretty
good with height you're already taller
than kevin
[Applause]
my name's tc
and i survived hall age
i've been actually been in hall age
two other times
one was back when they announced the bvs
announcement and they had the
you know right after man of steel
everyone was wondering what's going on
is this just a single movie or is this
going to be an entire universe and
that was a super hype announcement and
then the other time was
the time where kevin feige came out
previously and he went over i think it
was phase three and he announced um
infinity war
end game but at that point they were
called infinity war part 1 34 part 2.
that's where he did the captain america
um
serpent society and trolled us with that
and then really revealed it with civil
war so i went to two different hall h's
that were super hyped so
i had a lot of expectations going into
this one i'm gonna say that hall h this
year the h stands for here
my name is gordon
williams and i survived hall h
[Music]
so
if i had to say overall um
i think i would not feel the way that i
did
about
hall h the hall h experience and
everything
if
the process to get into what is
essentially a
panel
was not so
asinine
[Laughter]
right now
tony why are you posing the uber's
almost here come on man
cece why are you holding us up
get a shot of being between the palm
trees get a shot of me between the palm
trees exactly
how you doing today sir oh i've been
good thank you for asking how about
yourself uh pretty good thank you for
asking
is it very busy right now uh
so-so yeah
because of a comic-con yeah
are you a fan of superhero movies oh
hell yeah
you from san diego originally not really
man i'm from uh
i understand
we're recording a video for this vlog so
the title of this video is going to be
ups
so thank you for that sir
we're at target right now getting
foldable chairs to take to a hall each
line because it's either that or you're
going to be standing or
sitting in a very uncomfortable position
all day and night probably with an arch
back which
we already arched our backs enough at
home so save us
feel like such an [ __ ] making tc
carry everything
look we live in a world where people
have been joking for years about goku
being in fortnite
and now it is very likely going to
happen
do you want to tell everyone that we
made it to the hall h
wristband line to the hall age line
finally
uh
it was a long journey
a lot of walking in the heat a lot of
carrying very heavy bags but
it was all worth it because now we can
sit down and relax and we're around good
people so
hall h is always a grind right you're
gonna get here and you know the deal
you're gonna be waiting in line for
maybe a day half a day
and having to camp in the sun it's gonna
break your body especially you know i'm
getting older and also older folk
our bodies tend to break easily easier
but
yeah it's grueling man it's one of these
things where
it's become the norm
and expected by staff for people to
sit out and camp out
for long stretches of time to not even
get to essentially enjoy what is
essentially like
a convention and a convention is just a
gigantic party where you're able to you
know
celebrate the things that you love
and
on one hand it is very nice
because when you're getting to sit in
line you're getting to meet a whole
bunch of people and i think that that
part's kind of nice
but
i think that you can get that exact same
experience just being able to roam a
convention hall maybe get to play some
games with people hang out with
panelists and stuff like that it's
always a really good experience and i've
gone to conventions for years and that's
how it's always been
but then here
everyone is so
obsessed with being like oh i gotta be
there to see the first trailers as soon
as they drop
you can tell everybody how you got to
see it first and you have this situation
where
people are so obsessed with getting to
the optimal method
of getting into the hall
that
they care a lot less about having fun
they care a lot less about doing
anything else because they're going to
go for that optimal experience
of i want to get into the hall because
that's the thing
and just it's frustrating because i know
the kind of things that you can do at
cons and like
legitimately the idea of spending the
majority of your time at a convention
sitting and waiting in line is
legitimately
infuriating
it's interesting right like if you think
about the hall h line as a community
building um it's very interesting the
way that it's self-policed right you'll
have people that
get to know each other at least
peripherally right like we don't
necessarily know their names but we've
been looking at them for hours
i remember i'm like you're behind us
yeah yeah and then
the unit is with you tim i remember
right so i was like
it becomes a great exercise too because
you don't realize like how like we can
recognize a couple groups ahead of you
like nah they were there like we saw
them blah blah blah y'all remember like
it's kind of crazy the way that that
works
it's a great social experiment
i've experienced like camping out for a
thing before but never on this scale but
there's like 6 000 people waiting right
my experience is limited to camping out
for like a video game or something along
those lines and that's it
i never camped out for an iphone
nope
no
yeah okay so like the one time i camped
out for anything video game related uh
no but it was uh and while i was back in
college it used to be good but um
nonetheless no it's uh i never
experienced camping out for something on
this scale like on this level i had
never experienced that just this whole
process of pollination i've been through
it three times now
it puts expectations into you like
okay i'm doing all this i'm breaking my
body i'm getting sunburned on the back
of my neck i'm not being able to walk
the con floor because i'm sitting in a
line like this
better be good right that's it's just
like building expectations into you i
mean the cool thing was people were cool
and i think that's probably one of the
best things about camping out for hall
age is you can just check up a
conversation with anybody
right or just joining into a
conversation right like everybody knows
how it is right you hear people you're a
group of people talking you're like hey
i couldn't help it over here
conversation uh
are you guys talking about such and such
and it's just like yeah and then like
you're part of the conversation now
right
[Music]
see that's the risk you take though now
here's why i say my theory is that with
the multiverse
right disney has the fox properties yeah
oh yeah so they have the x-men fantastic
four yeah opens up a huge a whole thing
there's only there's only two directions
this is gonna be my first thought is
that secret wars is going to be avengers
forever by a different name you guys
know about that forever yes yeah so they
have their are you familiar with
avengers forever no that's right okay so
there's a story where basically it's the
past present and future avengers that
all come together for singularity okay
it was really cool yeah so so that would
be an opportunity to see tony stark
chris evans those guys come back
team up with the modern day avengers
maybe like moon night or something that
would be pretty awesome
um the alternative to that
is um they're gonna use it to reboot
everything it was a really cool
community i mean it really is just like
a giant line full of just hardcore fans
of
of like movie like nerdy and geeky
movies and stuff like that san diego's
it's not like it's freezing but where
the hall h line is it's by the coast
okay it's by the water and the wind is
cold and yeah i was freezing like
literally shivering and i looked
pathetic there in my chair shivering and
uh yeah at first
to keep myself warm and just to not just
be like this all the time i put my arm
into one of the folding chair sleeves
right some guy saw that he was next to
us uh
and uh he's like hey man you want this
black blanket and i was like oh yes man
i'll take it so just stuff like that
like
uh
people willing to like you know help you
out and just be kind like you don't see
that a lot online which you want because
everyone is anonymous and they can just
be the worst part of themselves but
when you actually touch grass and go out
into the real world uh people i feel are
generally uh kind
all right tc we're now in the final
stage of getting into hall
yep as soon as we pass these metal
detectors and we're gonna go meet up
with our group who we were waiting with
last night and this morning
and uh wait some more
it is a war zone under these tents when
it's the day of to get in there i could
not find where my people were so i was
just roaming around trying to find
like my dudes
and
no one was wearing masks people were
packed in there like sardines
it was a health hazard it was a fire
hazard and i felt legitimately disgusted
as someone who runs conventions
that i know 100 that there is a better
way
that does not
put people at risk you're cramming all
of these dudes together
people that are also still like shoving
and pushing and fighting people to get
into these spots in line a lot of the
time and then you're packing them in
like sardines when we're still in the
middle of two pandemics by the way two
pandemics by the way
uh with people not wearing masks
all crammed in like sardines and i'm
over here just like it is 2022 have you
learned
nothing
there's a better way institute a lottery
system
do something that takes the power away
from the people that want to game the
system and be obsessed because when you
go to a party when you go to a
convention when you go to a celebration
of something that you love the main
experience should not be
sitting around waiting in line like
everybody to say good morning home h
can we do that
all right one
two
three give it to me
[Music]
awesome you guys are great
no
it didn't live up to uh
the expectations i had in my head but
maybe my expectations were too high i
don't know i would only come back to
hall age
if
i had like a group of friends that were
like
you know
going to or enjoyed the camping aspect
um and they were like hey tc like no
don't worry about it you know we'll hold
down the line
and then you know you can come
on saturday morning the day in the
panels and come join us and then um you
know but also i'm not like that like i
like to put in my work too so it's not
like i would just
not show my face there at all and then
the day of saturday just show up hey
guys what's up like no i would put in
some hours but
i wouldn't put in
full days
days and a half type stuff no but that's
the only i think that's the only way i'd
kind of want to do haulage again
i think if you're coming out here for
strictly
uh marvel and dc hall age content
you can do that like from your home
really there's youtubers that stay home
they wait for the trailer to drop
because they're dropping some of these
trailers are dropping as soon as we see
them in the hall
and they're making their reaction videos
and they're good they're being first and
they're getting all the clicks like you
don't need to be here but the reason you
come
is to make those relationships to uh
build those uh friendships and stuff
like that i think that's that's why
everybody uh comes
if there's no expected like major
announcements and it's just
kind of an off year for lack of a better
word um
i probably wouldn't do it again um just
because i feel like as a comic book fan
specifically
i might find a little more enjoyment
taking that time walking the con floor
talking to my favorite creators and
things like that because you can't do
that when you're at hall age with the
amount of time that we used waiting in
line and despite the fact that i met a
lot of very cool people
i feel like i could have met those
people doing other things
and
in general it's going to be a relatively
hard sell
for me to want to do that
again
you